right thank you and thank you to the
organizers for the invitation thank you
to all of you for staying the last stop
of a long day try not to make it too
technical so this is joint work with a
student a former student now ji chang
who just graduated and is now working
for google ji zhu a long-time
collaborator of mine at university of
michigan and one half of it is also
joined with pay one who is at the Fred
Hutchinson Cancer Center so let me start
from a brief introduction to graphical
models just in case non-statistical
people quite familiar with the
terminology there different types of
graphical models people talk about I'm
just going to focus on this one
particular type of the graphical models
that represent conditional independence
relationships between a set of variables
so in the simple toy example here in
this toy graph if there is no edge
between say variables want to do that
means they are conditionally independent
given three four and five given
everything else whereas they these two
are dependent given 13 info I'm not
going to go into directional graphical
models so I'm not even going to attempt
in for anything causal so this is just
under action or just Association and
typically we don't know what this graph
is and we're trying to estimate it from
an observation zon P variables and of
course p could be large and with also
bueller and just to emphasize that from
the beginning this is not a prediction
problem unlike progression this is
basically exploratory data analysis
we're just trying to see what
relationships are on the data see what's
going on find interesting edges so
there's no prediction error that we can
really use to evaluate this here is one
wall studied example just to show you
what kind of thing you can get out of
doing it
um this is a data set on the US Senate
the variables here are senators there
are a hundred nodes this is data from
the 2005-2006 session to two years one
Senate so they all the same senators and
their the variables the observations of
the votes and all of that is publicly
available data and you just see they
vote yes or no um there's a lot of extra
little things you can do with it I'm not
going to go into this because that's not
really what I'm talking about but just
to show you what kind of information you
can get so you find the edges the
thickness here represents the strengths
of the Association that's the
proportional to the partial correlation
between variables so you can see what's
associated strongly the colors represent
positive or negative so of course
they're colored in the conventional way
the blue ones are Democrats the red ones
are Republican there is also one purple
independent in the middle of the
Democrats if you can see him Jeff earns
he votes with Democrats which you can
see from there so the red links and
negative associations there
anti-correlated of course and you find
things like what we know without any
graphical model anyway that the it's
extremely partisan but you also find
other things that are not necessarily
obvious it's just there are sub groups
and political scientists and people who
watch a lot of c-span which my
collaborator has happened to be and
really extract a lot of meaningful of
information out of this thing that
matches what they believe to be true
about the Senate politics so that's just
an example of an exploratory data
analysis using a graphical mode so how
do people fit these things primarily the
work the statistical work has focused on
two cases one is Gaussian graphical
models and people like studying them
because in Gaussian models independence
equals a zero correlation so all you
need to do to infer a Gaussian graphical
model is estimate the precision matrix
which is the workings amiga matrix is
the inverse of the covariance matrix of
the normal distribution and there has
been a lot of work on that and then
there is a one-to-one correspondence
between the zeros of that matrix and the
graphs so you can just read off the
graph from the covariance matrix before
people worried about big data and large
p um this problem has been looked at
already it goes at least back to
dempster 1972 and people just develop
hypothesis test type things for just
threshold in basically and selecting
large elements in 2006 nikolai man's
house and peter bulman proposed
neighborhood selection a very intuitive
idea of just progressing one variable on
the rest and looking at the coefficients
and doing last two and then if the
coefficients are non zero that means the
two things are dependent conditional and
everything else and then there has been
an enormous amount of work on estimating
precision matrices and various more
likelihood type ways with different
penalties this is perhaps the most
studied one this is now known as the
graphical la soo there's the G Laster
algorithm due to Friedman heat index
Ronnie and they're actually now newer
faster algorithms that can compute as
far as precision matrix on say a million
variables fairly quickly so this is
entirely doable and so that's but that's
all for gaussian models a lot of work
and then the other case that people have
looked at
fairly extensively is the Ising model
again because you can write down things
nicely and there you have a likelihood
this is in principle you can make it
work for discrete data but we'll just
focus on binary because it's simpler to
write down so saying you all your
variables are binary now instead of all
the variables being Gaussian typically
the likelihood people write down looks
like this you have main effects here and
then you have interaction terms and the
interaction terms tell you whether there
is an edge you know so if you zero out
some of these coefficients you get a
graph you can include higher order terms
in principle but difficulty people don't
because for the pairwise interaction you
just need second order terms so this
likelihood includes the normalizing
constant which is intractable so unlike
the Gaussian this is not easy to
estimate directly but people have found
ways around that of course and various
approximations to the likelihood have
been used such as surrogate likelihood
and pseudo likelihood and various other
ways you can also do something very much
like neighborhood selection except
because you now have binary data you
just run logistic regression instead of
this straightforward lawsuit but if you
run penalized logistic regression you
can also learn the graph that way where
you can penalize the likelihood or some
version of it so this is um all the work
that has been done a lot of good
algorithms have been developed which
some of them scale pretty reasonably and
here is the motivation for for what I'm
going to talk about which is very
dependent graphical model and this came
from a particular data set that I will
tell you more about later on generally
when people look at this they just have
i ad data i ad p variate vector
but in practice often you have other
information that you may be ignoring for
the graphical models but ideally should
take it into account and in this
particular case what what our
collaborator was interested in is a
genetic network so the variables on
which they wanted to construct the
graphical modeler jeans and this is a
breast cancer study so the data comes
from patients who all have breast cancer
but then they also know things about
these patients so they're not I ad they
have different tumor stages they have
different mutation status of a
particular gene which is well known to
be linked to breast cancer and other
things so what they wanted to know is
can we make this graphical model patient
dependent but not just patient dependent
but in an interpretable way so we can
find out what effects interactions
between which genes and say advanced
tumors cause these other genes to
interact in different ways so um you can
do this K very dependent thing for any
graphical model doesn't matter right
here just because of the application in
the application of the data is binary
I'll focus of the Ising model but it
doesn't really matter on and what the
goals that we have are the model that's
interpretable and continuous not really
continues but in the following sense
that if you have two patients that are
similar to each other but they have
similar coverage you want their
graphical models to be similar all right
so you want some kind of continued attea
across the space even though personal
space is completely discreet because
it's a graph and in some sense we want
them to be similar and of course
computationally feasible so um this
problem well we also not the first
people to look at it um it has been
looked at to some extent there's a
couple of papers here were the mean
so this is a Gaussian distribution where
think you know the mean was modeled as a
function of coverage and then you
subtract it off but then the precision
matrix was not and then he's to end up
with the same graph for everyone and we
really wanted different graphs then
leave it all looked at a very non
parametric approach to this where they
just practicin the covariance piece
suitably and then fit a different
graphical model to each part which gives
you a good fit but not the syrian
interpretation because the partition is
completely non parametric and you can't
really find out how it changes with
different values of the Coverity and a
former student of mine also looked at
fitting several related graphical models
jointly of course different categories
which you could think of as conditioning
on a single coverity just categorical
but that's of course very specialized we
want to be able to condition multiple
different governments but there has been
some to work in this direction so what
we did is it's fairly simple but it
satisfied our goals we just took the
Ising model and that in the standard in
the standard case there is no X here but
now we're modeling the parameters as
functions of covariance and we
parameterize them linearly because if we
do it linearly than we can easily
interpret the coefficients we have
continued eating we change one can I
write a little bit the model in
principle changes just a little bit and
it's also kind of X so computationally
that's very convenient we still can't
maximize the likelihood so we do the
usual thing and look at conditional
likelihood one variable given the rest
which is basically like running a
logistic regression just a more things
and we use the l1 penalty to do
selection to select edges and variants
like in all of these icing moodle's you
can
or actually in gaussian models as well
you can do these separate regressions
one at a time so regrets one note and
everything else then you end up with an
asymmetric solution so then you need to
do some kind of post hope symmetrization
it will usually take the minimum of the
maximum or you can estimate everything
jointly combine all these regressions
and then of course you have a much
larger parameter space over which to
minimize this thing so the first
approach is much faster computationally
and so that's what we use and we used up
of coordinate descent type algorithm
which as a version of what if you're
familiar with a gel m-net package it's
kind of freedom i hastened it for
anything it's some version of that so
it's reasonably fast it's not incredibly
fast but it's reasonable to just getting
back to the data example just to show
you what types of things you can get out
of this um as give you a little bit more
information the variables are deletion
events of tumor suppressor genes so we
believe that if you delete a gene that
suppresses a tumor that has effects on
concerned they want to know how it
varies across patients so there's a
hundred and forty three data points the
old breast cancer patients before
started therapy so the tumors are still
present in whatever stage they developed
to it starts out with about 40,000 DNA
copy number profiles which they combined
into 620 city bands to emphasize that
this wasn't us doing this in order to
reduce dimension it was done as part of
the data collection for bit of internal
reasons it basically increases the
signal-to-noise ratio they pull the data
because then there's the signal is
better so what we end up with is 620
dimensional binary vector and then just
three predictors two of which are binary
mutation status of a particular
well-known breast cancer gene and
estrogen receptor status which is also
something that's been shown to be
connected to breast cancer and then the
tumor category how advanced it is which
is an origin also it's a small set of
predictors in this particular study
could be bigger but still want to know
how these things matter so this is the
cut this is too big to close right and
the Senate you can just about make a
picture and look at it here you can try
to make a picture so what we look at is
the strongest ages and we did stability
selection on this which conveniently
richard has just explained in detail so
i don't have to go into this it's very
important to do something some version
of stability selection on any high
dimensional graphical model because they
known to be unstable and any one
particular graph is probably you can
probably find another graph that has a
similar value of the likelihood but if
you do stability selection and you see
edges that come up over and over and
over again then it is those edges you
can trust more so than the others and
that's what we focus on so these are the
variables and primarily the care they
care about interactions that are on
different chromosomes because things
that are close together on the same
chromosome are likely to contract anyway
for uninteresting reasons so those have
been omitted and you get the main effect
which means this edge is always there
but then we also get the other pairs
that are affected by a particular
predictor and I'm not going to go into
the biology of this and explanation but
they were quite happy with this because
it both profound certain associations
that have already been known from other
studies experimentally conferred and
other new things that they haven't known
before but that's sort of made sense
from some biological perspective
so this is also an output of a graphical
model not as pretty but now possibly
hopefully somewhat useful at least as a
guide for the biologists as to what they
should look at me being excellent
explore it has a high frequency just
very briefly mention theoretical
properties of this we focus on the
separate approach here which is what we
do in practice anyway um we just need
been so fair and standard kind of
penalized regression theory we need
standard assumptions on the design
matrix exponential decay on the tales of
the predictors and we get the usual kind
of results on parameter estimation
consistency so this is this is dead now
okay this one okay so should I use this
one then cuz this works three okay let's
see how long this one and and roughly
speaking the rate of convergence is
governed by this thing which looks quite
familiar i think to those who have
worked in this p is the number of
variables pues the number of covariance
so this makes sense and d is the largest
number of nonzero parameters / edge
which is the right measure of sparsity
for this it it matters not only how many
non zero edges you have altogether but
it matters even more how many non zero
parameters your log is solve / edge so I
don't want to go through this but just
in case you want to look at it this is
what the assumptions look like it's kind
of the standard representable condition
type of stuff and this is what the
theorem looks like so
that uniqueness and neural consistency
and model selection consistency I'm
going to skip that but just a quick
simulation again just to show that the
number of nonzero parameters / edge
really matters so in this case we this
works better as the point we just use
that we vary the total number of edges
present in the graph that goes across 10
20 30 and we also vary the proportion of
nonzero coefficients so that's this row
here point two point five point eight
and so you can see if you go across the
rows and this is joint versus separate
so those are quite close if you go
across the rows nothing much happens and
it slowly does decay as you as it
becomes law sports as you would expect
but as you change the proportion of
nonzero parameters / edge it true
actually affects it much more so so it's
kind of a maximum no degree idea which
which matters for this okay let me so
that's that was for so that was very
dependent here
this one
oh yeah I think this one should be out
soon I think so yeah I think that's a
typo okay yeah because here there will
be yeah I come from person yeah I think
any parent look that's where it usually
would be okay so for the arm for the
mixed the mix of graphical model that
was another extension of the graphical
model that we looked at again motivated
by practice was actually a question I've
I've got them in talks multiple times
usually from very applied people who had
data that they wanted to analyze and I
used to work on a lot of precision
matrix estimation so talked about that
and they would say well and I really
like this and I want to do this and my
dataset has discrete variables and
continuous variables which a lot of
datasets do right and then you can't
actually do that right you can't do the
Gaussian model and you can't do the
Ising model because they're mixed and
that just seemed very unsatisfactory
somehow it seems like something that we
should be able to handle so we went back
and looked at the literature and checked
what anybody ever looked at that and of
course people have so suppose you're in
a setting where you now have X that
consists of two parts Z is binary again
you can make a discreet in general but
it's easier to write stuff down for
binary so it's a binary and why is
continues there are q binary variables P
continuous variables and Lauridsen
vermis arm introduced something they
called a conditional Gaussian
distribution for jointly modeling things
like that in the context of graphical
models this is also in fluorescence
graphical models but and this is what it
looks likes if you look at this
carefully than what you see is a
Gaussian
right so why is the continuous part so
this is just the Gaussian density but
all the parameters depend on the binary
vector so that means that for every
possible combination of the binary
variables there is a different Gaussian
to fit and so that's of course too many
gaussians if you have a lot of variables
that's two to the Q different Gaussian
so that becomes infeasible very good
they they also derived them the
canonical representation which is what
you need to relate parameters to a graph
and in Gaussian case it's very simple
here it's a little bit more complicated
but they derive this again this this
looks very complicated but basically
what it says is that so these g z h z kz
these are the parameters of the Gaussian
and what it's and what it says is that
you can write each one of them as a sum
of these parameters over all the subsets
of the graph so these are all the
subsets of the indices of the discrete
part and then you write it that in that
way and basically it tells you what has
to be 0 in order to know that there is
no edge in the graph one I'll i won't go
into the detail of this sort of more
general formulation once we look at it
and the more specific case it will be
more intuitive hopefully so that that
model has to do the Q times P squared
parameters so we can't really fit it at
all unless we do something with it if Q
is large and so what we did is truncated
basically and instead of looking at the
sum over all possible subsets so so
overall the clicks in the graph
we just look at truncated subsets here
up to size 2 and in these terms of the
size 1 why these particular truncation y
2 and 1 that's because this is the
smallest possible model that gives us
all graphs so this model still allows
all possible interactions between binary
variables and binary two gaussian and
within gals if we truncated any further
than some edges will just be impossible
to help so now this has just most Q
squared parameters in terms of fuel p
square times q whichever one is larger
still not so small but manageable and it
includes all possible grubs and now we
can for this model it's much easier to
read all conditional independence if you
look at where the interactions are you
can basically see them right you can see
where the two Z's are multiplied
together so if there is no edge between
two discrete variables that's the
parameter that needs to be 0 there is a
little bit of a complication here
because the discrete and the continuous
variables y and z interact in multiple
places and two places so if you want to
remove an edge between a binary variable
and a continuous variable you need a
whole set of parameters that needs to be
set to 0 so it's a group so it's like in
the group plus so you have 20 out a
whole group and also these groups
overlap as you can see these these
parameters coming from the Coverity
covariance matrix appear in two sets of
edges so it is a little bit like July
soo where you just want to zero out
parameters except they come in groups
and groups overlap so it's more
complicated
get to mention related work which maybe
I should have an earlier hasty and his
student Jason Lee [ __ ] think is here
who was here earlier looked at basically
what turns out to be a special case of
our model where the currents of Hawaii
is independent of Z it's simpler to fit
but doesn't include all possible graphs
and this group which is Peter Bowman and
his collaborators looked at mixed models
as well with discrete and continuous
variables doing neighborhood selection
using just random forests so completely
non parametrically I guess so they get
selection but there's no generative
model so you can't analyze it if you're
so inclined you can't interpret to the
parameters so how do we fit this again
because we have binary variables as part
of it we have an intractable constant so
we can't do likelihood so again we'll
look at conditional log likelihood which
is a lot like neighborhood selection and
if you write down the conditional
likelihood and simplify it and see what
it reduces to you find that it's
actually quite simple it reduces to
linear regression with these terms for
continuous variables and logistic
regression with this set of terms for
binary variables so that's something
that we know how to do very well except
these parameters are in overlapping
groups so if we just use the regular
lasso then we won't be able to guarantee
that with zero out the whole group we
could use group plus so actually many
proposals now on how to on different
penalties that allow you to zero out a
whole group of parameters at the same
time this is one of them which has been
used a fair amount the two norm instead
of one norm but that's computationally
much more difficult and say lasso and
especially with
overlap so it's kind of tricky so we
ended up doing sort of something in
between which worked out quite well
empirically at least we wanted to do the
l2 penalty but that was just too
complicated so well I say approximated
central n fluctuations in upper bound
write the 2 norm is bounded by the one
norm and in this toy example so I'd say
I just have three parameters and they
are in two groups of two and the second
one is in both groups right so they
overlap this is what these two feasible
regions look like so by using the l1
bound we're making it smaller but almost
all the feasible points are almost all
the corners really are the same right so
they coincide so it's a it's a
reasonable approximation and then it
reduces to just the last two except with
weights because then the the overlapped
parameter the parameter that appeared in
both groups is counted twice let me skip
this and then all we have to do is do
regression either regular linear
regression or logistic with weighted l1
penalties but the weights are fixed they
actually either one or two depending on
whether that's an overlapping for a
betrayal they don't depend on the data
they are not adaptive so in terms of
asymptotic behavior it's basically just
standard and a fluster type asymptotics
we just went through it and so that we
can still do it all only need to do is
basically rescale the design matrix to
account for the weights and then
understand there's some sort of holder
I'm not going to write it out all we
just finished with a quick example this
is this is purely for comic relief ad
and
they just not cancer or anything like
that this is a music data set there are
five hundred and two observations which
are songs there are 120 discrete
variables which are labels assigned to
them by human experts which tell you
things like the genre of the music what
instrument it uses what kind of usage
would be good usage for that music and
so on so these are kind of soft labels
supplied by humans and then there are
continuous features which are hard
features just extracted from the audio
signal from the time series of the audio
signal which are basically various
functions of the freer coefficients and
they also represent certain features of
the signals such as brightness and
noisiness and amplitude and so and so
this is the kind of picture you can get
here these squares are the continuous
variables so that's the audio data the
round ones are the labels so you can see
that you get some interactions because
you get a lot of interactions within the
continuous variables which you would
expect because they all coming from the
same time series but you also get
interactions between continuous and
discrete variables and of course within
discrete ones as well the different
colors represent different types of
labels which you can treat here but just
some some selected edges such as say
noisiness is associated with negative
feelings whereas likable songs are
associated with driving for some reason
so it's just their stuff that you can
extract that which sort of makes sense
um and you find things that connect this
sort of hard date and soft data which is
good nice but this is just for intruding
so um let me wrap up and
just say that graphical models with all
their shortcomings and high dimensions
are as I think still a nice exploratory
tool if you just want to look at the
data and see what connections there are
a lot of times in real applications they
need to be more flexible than just the
standard Gaussian model say because
there are more complicated things going
on so the two particular scenarios that
we looked at is conditioning on
covariance when you get a covariance or
a subject specific model so you can
interpret stuff and mixed models just
allow you to feed discrete and
continuous variables together which he
really should be able to do was a
statistician a lots of other open
questions arm such as learning mixtures
of graphical models and an unsupervised
fashion if you have data that comes from
different models you think what you
don't know which ones there could be
much more complex coverage relationships
one could explore and ultimately
combining graphical models with network
models which actually network models is
something that I work on a lot too much
more than graphical models now and they
have two separate literature's
developing in parallel which would be
nice to connect together and also of
course computational facilities we
wanted to scale as the de la senal
skills to millions of variables for
these more complicated things that we
need to do more work and these are the
two references to the papers that I
talked about they're both on the archive
for the holiday
so do you have a choice just like the
neighborhood selection you can do a
different partner for each but then
that's a lot of cost a lot of parameters
titude or you can just do
you